on camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you had you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm
going to do you're going to resign I'm
going I've been answering your question
you answer mine it's actually not my job
to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV tonight on Pi Morgan uncensored I've
come to Beverly Hills in California to
sit down with one of America's
unofficial royal family Priscilla
Presley was married to Elvis Presley the
king and they had one child a daughter
Lisa Marie who very sadly died earlier
this year this is the first interview
that Priscilla has given since that
tragic event and it's the first time
she's talked on camera since the release
of a movie about her life called
Priscilla What followed in more than an
hour was one of the most moving you know
I lost my mom then I lost my grandson
and then I lost my daughter emotional
talk
anymore revealing she was feeling almost
suicidal herself I think so and
surprising interviews that I've done my
entire
[Music]
career Priscilla first of all how are
you I'm okay thank you I'm good you've
had a kind of extraordinary few years
really um some great highs some terrible
lows and I've interviewed you various
stages in the last 15 years or so and
before I came today I was I was just
wondering actually genuinely how you
were do
it well in all honesty um you know it
has been pretty tough you know I lost my
mom then I lost my grandson and then I
lost my daughter so I don't know exactly
how to answer that because I have my
good days and I have my bad days so you
know you just you never know and uh it's
um how could I say it's
uh it's difficult it's difficult to wake
up in the morning and and not you know
have a call from my daughter or wonder
how my grandson is doing it's like a
part of your not part but a large part
of your life is taken
away the particular difficulty for
someone like you is that you can't do
this privately everything is magnified
on a global stage right and there was a
quote which really resonated with me I
suspect it will with you from baz lurman
who of course directed Elvis the movie
and he said there's the kennedies and
there's the Presley they are the royal
families of America and in different
ways they both were as Shakespeare says
wedded to Calamity is it genetic is it
because they have such high standards is
it because the world watches them maybe
because to be American royalty is not
just to have your country watch you to
be American royalty is to have the whole
world watch you mhm did that resonate
with you absolutely
absolutely you know um when you're
living a life you know I mean being
married to Elvis Presley you don't
really know what you're getting into
especially when you're younger and
um you know you have to adapt
to not really having your
privacy um things getting out that you
wish didn't um you start uh thinking my
gosh you know I I have to be careful you
know what I say or it'll be taken wrong
or they'll add on to it so it's it's a
it's been a journey there's no
doubt there's a movie now about
you your Center Stage it's your life
it's called
Priscilla and when they first add it at
the Venice Film Festival you were there
and at the end there's a very moving
clip as you get a standing ovation from
about seven minutes yeah from an
ecstatic crowd and you're in tears at
the
end what was it that moved you in that
moment for the uh the for the the movie
getting that kind of reception I never
you know when you have a movie that's
about
you um you never know how people are
going to take it um you never know if
they're going to understand it I mean
they have their own you know with all
this
people you know that's a big name it's a
big name
and I was happy because um it had a
standing ovation I was happy for Sophia
she was quite nervous about it sopop
Sophia Copa right is it an accurate
depiction do you think not just of you
but of your relationship with Elvis I
think so I think she did a she did a you
know I mean she did some homework I mean
she and I we talked about it
and um you know living with Elvis
Presley people think oh how wonderful
that's great it's Elvis Presley but I
went through the ups and downs with him
you know a very crucial part of his life
um you know his ups and downs um his
struggles
uh you know his uh
fears so you know you when you're living
with someone so
famous uh and you been through it with
them it's that part of privacy that
you're it's hard to give up it's hard to
share it's hard to you know I don't want
to give out too much because I want some
of that myself that's just for me and
actually one of the reasons it's reputed
that Elvis loved you so much was that
from the very first moments that you
were together even though you were very
young and you were at school and we'll
come to that you never spoke about him
to people right absolutely respected and
protected his privacy even though at the
time he one of the biggest stars in the
world and that really endeared you to
him the fact that you safeguarded the
Privacy I did when I first started
dating him or let's say you know he
would call to to my parents to see if I
could um come over just on the weekends
you know maybe Friday maybe a Saturday
that whole I mean part of my life was um
getting to know him but the question was
why
me why is he drawn to me why is he
asking my mother and father if it's okay
if you know I would go visit and when I
put all the pieces together it's because
I really I was The
Listener I was the one that he
trusted um more I think than
[Music]
anyone and I honored that and I would
never give that up
um I never told kids at school that I
was seeing him no one even
knew because I valued that trust um and
why and I would ask the question why me
why does he trust me um I was the
listener he would tell me about how
upset he was with his father who was who
actually he lost his mother uh a year
before he went to the Army and then his
father met this woman who had three
children
and he couldn't believe his father I
couldn't believe yes that his father
would so soon start dating and falling
in
love and then he would pour his heart
out uh to me get emotional about it
because he was so close to his mother so
I look at the trust Factor meant a lot
to him a lot and to this day you know
there are things I hold to my heart and
and I won't give up you never bad mouth
Elvis I've noticed that about you your
entire life no you've never had even
though you got divorced and everything
else you've been an impeccable support
to him even decades after his death it
obviously matters to you a lot a lot he
was a very special human being and to be
put in the position that he was never
expecting to be as big as he became you
know he just loved his music he loved to
sing he loved to entertain people and
that's what he started out until much to
his surprise he was received so well and
I remember being in Las Vegas and it was
always a packed I mean literally he he
sold out every
night and he looked in the audience and
he'd see it full every single night and
then he'd go later on and start touring
and they would be sold out every night
and he said to me you know I see all
these people coming to see me and I
don't understand why am I to do and be
something else is there a message for me
that maybe I should be preaching maybe I
have a message for people and he would
bring out the Bible at night sometimes
and look and read and not that he
compared himself to Jesus in any way he
he read the Bible all the time it was
just it was just him thinking maybe I'm
here for another purpose a message to
give and people you know when I when I
have said that very rarely um it's
something that it weighed on him one of
the contentious points of the movie it's
one of the contentious points about your
relationship with Elvis which is when
you met him you were 14 and he was 24
how do you think the movie deals with
that some people who've reviewed it say
well you can see there he's he's
grooming her um others saying that know
post me too he would have been cancelled
for the this kind of thing what do you
feel about it because it was a different
time it was the early 60s the early 60s
and you know I I compare this to my
mother my mother my father was in the
military my mother would dress up for my
father every day when he came home from
work she was dressed up that was that
and women were that way we we were you
know not that it was just for our men
but we took care of ourselves and we
wanted to be um when I say we I I I
include myself
um we respected my mother respected my
father uh and other women wore dresses
back in the day they did not wear pants
slacks
jeans uh so that was just the time it
was I mean you know Elvis was was um
like I said he was very unique but he
was uh I don't know about grooming me he
I didn't take it at that I never heard
the word I mean obviously it's all new
now but you know he loved to take me to
to um beautiful uh stores to buy me a an
outfit I didn't have any money I he
would take me you know to the movies
every night that's when you dressed up
and he wanted me to be to look good and
not feel bad that I had jeans or not
jeans but you know a little dress that
didn't really fit uh for or be suitable
for where we were going so um so yes he
would buy clothes for me and and and
love to and look at when you see what he
wore he would dress up to a tea so he
wanted to me wanted me also to be
dressed up but people today with the
mindset of today will look back and say
it was inappropriate that he would be
with a girl of 14 what do you say to
people that think M I understand I
understand but um I was 14 in Germany
and um my I was uh there was always
people around um uh and our talks were
yes private but he never ever ever was
aggressive nor did he ever make love to
me um I was somehow like I said earlier
someone he trusted to talk to and pour
his heart out and famously you only
consumated your relationship on your
wedding night that's right in fact
that's when Lisa Marie was conceived
that's right that night and you were 21
I think when you got married mhm no one
would believe that but it's the honest
of God truth yeah I believe it yep I've
seen you say it before
yep in the movie again depending what
your mindset is I think you could either
say as some people have done that Elvis
comes off as kind of distant emotionally
abusive to a degree um a drug addict
obviously people knew that towards the
end of his life life um quite a negative
characterization but other people have
said in the same light that you just did
about it that it was a different time
and that actually he was also coping
with the extraordinary pressures yes of
being the biggest superstar in the world
yes and that brings with it unique
challenges he had a lot on his shoulders
to take care of to do he had you know
films that he hated all of them actually
except the first two really yes he was
you know he felt that he was being a
joke you know to have this kind of on
the beach girls girls girls and that's
all really what hell Wallace gave him
Colonel Parker signed a five-year
contract with with Hal Wallace and uh
never cared about what kind of movies
they were Elvis was frustrated at the
fact that he couldn't get roles that he
wanted um and uh Colonel just didn't
understand his client at all what was he
like Colonel B yeah um colonel
does he like the Tom Hanks portrayal in
the
movie uh somewhat but um Colonel I never
had a problem with Colonel it's just
when Colonel Parker interfered with
Elvis's choice of
songs um that's when it really that's
part of the movie and when he's upset
because colonel was you know trying to
change the music and wanting him to sing
a different song or talk to a producer
and said he should be doing this when he
got in Elvis's way
that's when Elvis would go to go all out
did you did you feel Elvis was a
controlling influence on you um
controlling I I don't think it was
controlling I never thought about it
being controlling you were 16 when you
first went to graceand 17 17 MH I mean
again a crazy experience for a young
teenage woman to suddenly be propelled
from a very normal life into this
do you remember it vividly the first few
experiences there well when um when I
first went to graceand to visit it was
in June of 62 I believe and
[Music]
um I I um no was' 63 it was I was in
Vegas in ' 62 okay
63 Elvis um was there and he wanted uh
for me to close my eyes is when they
drove up to the gate cuz I had heard
about grain he told me all about Gracin
and I would love Gracin it's so
beautiful and I mean he he he loved grin
that was his home and the first home he
ever bought so I closed my eyes and um
he asked the driver to have the gates
open and you could see the beautiful
Gates and they'd start they'd open up
and the lights were on it was so
beautiful I I more than what I ever
expected but he was so proud of it and
to not just to me to show people and and
to um take them around the house and the
grounds and and it was it was it was
beautiful it was a nice moment it was a
magical place in many ways and yet what
comes through from the movie is that he
would go off and make his movies and
while he was away you were often left
for long periods of time on your own in
this extraordinary place and but
actually life there could be quite dull
you were with Elvis Presley but life for
a lot of the time for you was not wildly
exciting at all there was a lot of
telephone calls right he would always
call me at 5:00 in the evening and I
would wait for phone call every night
yes and you'd be there ready I'd be
there by the
phone and there's this sort of sense you
get in the movie and you get it whenever
you read about Elvis you would know
better than anybody obviously that when
he walked into a room energy levels
through the roof I mean he was El presly
the the Charisma was just crazy even if
he wasn't in a great mood it was still
crazy this Charisma do you do you
remember that oh my God yes he'd walk
into the room and it's like wow I mean
he he didn't realize you know what he
had as far as his appearance or what he
felt or his Charisma but um there was a
few times when he'd K around and he said
damn I'm
goodlooking kiddingly when he would be
in his his um bathroom and he'd be
getting ready to go somewhere but he had
a great great sense of
humor
[Applause]
[Music]
let let's talk about you you split from
Elvis and you get divorce from Elvis but
you have
this little girl Lisa Marie and she's
your child that you have with Elvis His
only
child what was that relationship ship
like after the divorce between the three
of you would you say well I because when
I left I wanted I you know I he adored
her and I never wanted to take that away
from him so I made arrangements that on
Christmas or holidays or Easter that she
that he it was a point that that I would
send her to Gracin of course the nannies
was there with her are we bring her
there that that he had time alone with
her so even in and in uh Las Vegas the
same thing I I wanted them you know to
be close which they were and be was he a
good father despite all the problems he
was having he was as good a father as he
could be you know he was never around
children and you know it was you know
growing up so he really honestly when he
was she was smaller he didn't quite know
what to do with her um but as as she got
a little bit older and a little bit
older and then she could travel you know
to visit him and be with him for at
least two weeks you know when it was um
Christmas or Easter or something then he
became closer to
her his death was something that shook
the entire world but for you and your
daughter it must have been a
particularly seismic shocking
moment devastating to get a call
absolutely devastating I had just talked
to him the night before
actually and I um no two nights before
and it to get that call um Jo bazito
actually called me and said
s um Elvis is dead and he was already
emotional and
I just yell you know I thought he was
kidding you know you you just never
imagine that that we would joke around
all the
time and then when I found out that you
know it was true and I just went to my
bedroom and just stayed and Joe said you
send the plane for me the private
plane and I just stayed in my room and
couldn't believe it and cried and I
don't
know it's it's interesting even now this
is 50 years ago pretty much nearly yeah
but it still has aound effect I can
still hear Joe Esposito's words so oh
this is dead
and that was like I couldn't I just
couldn't imagine him ever you know
especially you know his age and all
being so still so young and wanting to
do so much and had so much planned and
not having him not having him not
talking to
him um not having him be the father of
our child and what you know my big fear
was Lisa you know and how do I how do I
tell her and
she was only nine at the time I have a
daughter of 11 I can't imagine a harder
conversation to have right how how did
you tell her well I just told her we're
going to Gracin and where we're going to
go see Daddy but Daddy won't be you know
Daddy will be
resting and she just asked me and she
goes well what resting I've never
actually told this before because it's
been hard but um I said well he's going
to go to sleep for a while and she goes
will I be able to see him him and I said
yes you'll be able to see him you'll be
able to see him and then she sees him
and uh I don't think she really quite
got it but uh because she went out in
the golf cart and started uh she had a
little friend and driving in the golf
cart and all around the backyard of
grin so I don't it didn't really hit her
until later I can't even imagine because
it was such a huge story for the rest of
the world but for you this is just this
this is real life this is your man that
you loved still loved still loved today
still up today yep he was like I said he
was unique he was um his personality was
Unreal he was
caring
um he cared for people he had um he
wondered why him um and when I mean he
there's stories about him I don't know
if you ever heard the story about a
there was a black woman woman who was um
looking at a car on Bill Street uh a car
dealership and he was looking he was
just driving around and he saw her
looking in the in the windows at the new
cars that were there and he said told
Charlie to stop the car he stopped out
and he went over to the woman and he
goes boy those are nice cars and he said
oh yes sir they're beautiful look at
that and he goes what one do you like
and he she goes oo I like that black one
right there no that blue one right there
and he goes really yeah I kind of like
that too so then he takes her in and
they go in see the car and she he says
what do you think oh that's a beautiful
car you'll be good in that car right he
goes well just a minute he goes and gets
a Salesman he says give me the keys to
that car I'm getting it and he gives the
keys to her and that's with a beautiful
blue Cadillac brand new that's him
that's what he would do anyone in
trouble he'd give them money anyone who
had you know a problem with anything
really you know and they couldn't afford
it even with some of the guys who needed
uh medical care he'd pay for it when
you've watched Elvis the movie in our
Priscilla and it's made you revisit all
of these times that you had with him do
you have any part of you that thinks if
only I'd done this this or this things
could have turned out different you know
I don't know I don't think so because I
I really um you know I gave my all to
him I I you know I couldn't I couldn't
change his mind I mean he was strong
minded well I think he he loved you and
you loved him till the day he died I
that's clear yes it was an extraordinary
love story he would call me all the time
and it was so funny because whoever he
was with he would usually go into his
bathroom to make the phone calls do you
remember your last conversation with
him my last conversation yes was when
Lisa was coming home that she needed to
come home because school was starting
and Lisa Lisa was there during that
time
yeah that was it it's very I mean it's
it's very poignant for me to talk to you
who's in the end you're you're a woman
that had this extraordinary life and had
this extraordinary relationship with
this man but here we are I think he died
in 1977 MH and here we are in
2023 and like I can see the effect he
still has on you just on a personal
human level there's nothing tabloid or
anything about this this was a real
visceral love affair between you I miss
him I miss him very much yeah I miss his
words I miss his love I miss his laugh I
miss his energy I miss the fun times I
think you know you don't really realize
the fun times that you're having until
you go back and you look at your album
albums and your pictures and you go oh
my God we had so much fun we did so much
and uh you know it's still it's still
there is there a song that whenever you
hear
it you think for whatever reason as one
song it is
memories
memories press between the pages of my
mind really
mhm press between the pages of my
mind yeah I do I don't listen to them
that songs very often because it just
you know I go into you know another
place but I I know sometimes I I am a
little
um surprised at myself that I still get
emotional and um I still I you know love
is still there it's amazing really some
people many people I think might go
through their entire lives without ever
having that
feeling well I think too I think too is
because he's so present he's still so
present he's still so affects people but
he you know it it's like when I go to
Vegas sometimes you know I think my God
that you go to the Hilton Hotel you see
these big showrooms you go if people
it's never Vegas has never been the same
I think I don't think there was only one
Elis I mean they there are lots of
Pretenders to the crown but there's
never been anyone like him right it's
since he died it's true you know in the
movie um Sophia did
um which he was angry you know with
Colonel Parker and you know yes he was
angry and yes he threw the chair or
whatever but he he would when he was
angry he would go especially with
Colonel Parker he would go into that
moment you know because he just felt
that colonel was you know colonel was
really uh deceiving him in many ways
that he wasn't giving him what he wanted
and yet he would talk behind his back I
mean Sophia was never making that movie
to show at the bad side of of us that
was a real moment when he was upset with
Colonel Parker and it showed that he yes
he had a temper yes that's you know what
he felt you know that moment but that
didn't mean he was like that all the
time hardly but he knew what he wanted
and he didn't want you know someone to
go against him when he knew and he did
his instincts were absolutely right yes
absolutely right so you know people walk
out oh my God he's got oh my God he was
no he was a human being and he had
feelings and yes he had a temper he
didn't show it that much but when he did
he had every reason
to
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic at
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening up Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm three days into the job what
have I done wrong and your face just
starred out at me me and you conquer
time who wins you do you know what I
love about tour today we do it all sunak
sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
richy I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of boozed up Brits
against these pom you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L
not stop ping to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google and Facebook and X
formly known as Twitter where is our
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Welcome to the talk it's really
great to be back my Little Darlings kids
think all they have to do is stay at
home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tok then
yeah problem solved there you go who's
fit as a butchest dog him all right
but but he's now middle class here Tess
I nearly have empathy when I'm speaking
to them I know now you're probably going
to boot me off show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King
cute I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying just
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
folk when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing the
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
have you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
not only the home of common sense it's
the only place where you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV when you when you're out and about
when you get on planes or wherever you
may go how do people react to
you they're friendly very friendly
someone told me that often they'll
they'll clap yeah sometimes they
that's amazing I know I know there's a a
horrible irony in many ways that it was
literally at the moment that the Elvis
movie was being fed at the Golden Globes
and you attended with Lisa Marie that
within 48 Hours of that she incredibly
sadly died in her mid
50s what was I I've read an account that
you both went to chat Mar Mo and you
were laughing together as a mother and
daughter um and everything seemed fine
and then she suddenly said to you that
she was having these crippling stomach
pains yeah did you did you fear there
was something very bad happening well I
I she didn't look well that night and I
was
concerned and uh she asked Jerry
Schilling who is a good friend of mine
very one of my best friends if not the
best friend um if he she could if he
could hold her her heels were high and
and she's worn them before and I thought
is she okay she didn't really look that
okay she looked very frail so I let that
go and then uh we watched the show and
uh we had a few laughs and and we were
all excited about Austin Butler and you
know baz and you know the movie went so
well we're proud of them and you know
and then we started to go and she said
mom you want to go to chatau Mama and
have a drink and I said sure and then we
went there and sat down and um she mom I
have to go my my stomach really hurts
and I go of course you okay she goes
yeah yeah just I really have to go and I
go okay okay we'll get the cars now and
then we walked toward the car and like I
hugged her and U she went her way and I
went mine and that was that hug was the
last was the last hug I gave her and
it's still shocking
that um you know I don't we don't have
her
I I got that call from her um ex-husband
Danny that uh you know I need that I
need to go to the hospital see Lisa that
she's in the hospital and then I thought
oh my God you know this is not the first
time but I never thought that it was
last and it was too late you you didn't
too late watch you to the AL
yeah I mean they say that it's the worst
possible thing to lose a
child I given your relationship how
close you were what you'd all what you'd
been through as a family it must have
been particularly painful unbearable
well it is it was unbearable you know I
lost my mother I lost my grandson and I
lost my
daughter and um losing Ben was was
was that was the hardest thing for her
losing Ben because he took his own life
he took his own life and he was I mean
he
was the love of her life that child she
adored him she would do anything for him
anything and um we were in Memphis we
sitting up in the suite and she said
mom you know I don't know I don't know I
don't know if I want to be here and I go
what are you talking
about you know my Ben and she'd go on
about Ben and how she is still grieving
and this was a couple of months before
and she was feeling almost suicidal
herself I think
so she really she was almost like I she
wanted to go earlier but the the Twins
were still
young or Too Young let's put it that way
so Twins were what
13 it's so
sad I know don't talk anymore
that can you stop the camera please
C
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry about that no of course
be completely understandable um Lisa of
course at one stage was married briefly
to Michael Jackson right arguably after
Elvis the other great pop icon has ever
been were you concerned mhm about that
mhm
very yeah and I was honest with
her you know she told me she was seeing
him
and you know she was seeing him for a
little bit actually and then I remember
being in Hawaii and she was we were
walking together on the beach and she
said Mom I'm really concerned and I go I
this is while they were married and said
that you know I never see him I go what
do you mean you never see him he's
always
gone I go where does he go and she goes
I don't know I don't know where he goes
he'll call me maybe three or four days
later I said well don't you ask him
where he's going he goes he just said
you know he's around he has things to do
and I always felt that you
know Michael you know Jackson Lisa
Presley and he he you know loved Elvis
or respected
Elvis so I always felt excuse me that
having the name you know um being
associated with the name with his
daughter yeah I did I was concerned I
told her thought maybe that was his main
motivation I I did did you I did I mean
know I I know he was a bit fearful of me
and she told me you know he's afraid of
you and I go what is your Afra afraid of
me for why is he afraid why should he be
afraid of me and she goes I don't know
he doesn't think you'll like him I said
I've hardly talk to him because he
always hides right we were at the peab
Buddy Hotel in Memphis and um I went to
see her at her suweet and and we're
talking and then all of a sudden I said
well where's Michel said he's getting
dressed and I go okay so I he pops out
really quickly to get his hat that was
left on the end table and then rushes
back and cl of the door I said God do I
scare him that
much was it was it do you think because
he knew you saw through him a bit yeah I
think I think he's I I think he was
quite smart and I think he did yeah I
think he did but um she then told me
that you know they were getting that she
wanted a divorce and and then the rest
is history
yeah the don't get me wrong I thought he
was very talented um truly talented and
but I never really got to know him and
you would have preferred him not to
marry your daughter yeah I just because
I felt that he was so intrigued about
Elvis and you know just you know here's
Lisa
and is he with her because she's Lisa or
because she's a Presley I think more
because she was a Presley
yeah after Lisa died it was widely
reported obviously that there was a
dispute between you and Riley her
daughter and it's all been settled oh
yeah and Riley gave an interesting
interview to Vanity Fair and I thought
there was some there were some wonderful
lines there I thought because it really
resonated with me for any F any family
particularly a family like yours which
has all the added outside pressures and
of course huge amounts of money with the
estate and everything else um and she
said when my mom passed there was all a
chaos in every respect of Our Lives
everything felt like the carpet had been
ripped out and the floor had melted from
under us everyone was in a bit of a
panic to understand how we move forward
and it took a minute to understand the
details of the situation because it's
complicated we're a family but there's a
huge business side of our family so I
think that there was Clarity that needed
to be had and Clarity is being had and
they then asked are things with Grandma
happy and she said a really interesting
response things with Grandma will be
happy they've never not been happy she
said I'm trying to think of a way to
answer it's not a 20-minute conversation
there was a bit of an upheaval then she
said this about you she's a beautiful
woman and she was a huge part of
creating my grandfather's Legacy in
graceand it was very important to her he
was a love of her life anything that was
suggest otherwise in the Press makes me
sad because at the end of the day all
she wants is to love and protect graand
and the Presley family and the Legacy
that's her whole life it's a big respons
responsibility she tried to take on none
of that stuff has ever really been a
part of our relationship prior she's
just been my grandma and I thought that
was actually a lovely way to describe it
yeah I I never read that wow wow I'm
going to cry
again yeah how does that feel oh my God
I love her I mean I've we have always
gotten along you know I think it was the
press that really started all this and
you know it's like like like everything
else they don't give you you know they
don't when something comes out like yes
it was a little bit of um trying to
figure out will trying to figure out you
know like you normally do but Riley and
I have always been close I mean at the
center of it it seemed quite
straightforward that Lisa Marie had
changed her will but hadn't actually
told you and in changing it she'd made
the executiv or Trustees of the will
were to be her children which is
perfectly understandable absolutely you
just didn't know so when she suddenly
dies tragically young and this all comes
out you just were caught blindsided
that's what it seemed to me that's all
it was that was all it was you know and
I think Riley will be great um she's you
know asked me a few things about what to
do and where we'll we'll talk about like
I want to I want to help her like with
Gracin I mean she has her own career as
well and doing so well with her she's
very talented she's so talented so
you're incredibly talented family aren't
you I mean putting aside all the drama
and the heartache and all the other
stuff underpinning it a lot of very
talented people thank you in your family
thank you I think so as well even Ben
was was quite talented as well and he
had dreams but um but uh with Riley um I
told her anything she needs to know
about Grace about Elvis more so about
Elvis because you know she never really
took a part of of of going to graceand
only on special times whether it be
Christmas or you know we'd all go for I
don't know for some occasion not that
many times but uh I want her you know to
know a lot about Elvis and um I'll
probably you know help her in that way
she was asked in the interview about
this stuff that had been gossiped about
let's put it like that that there may be
some issue about whether you would one
day be buried with Elvis and graceand
Ben is obviously there Lisa Marie is
there now and she said as far as she was
concerned absolutely do you want to
clear that up I mean how are your
feelings about that well I because my
feelings are great I mean that's you
know what what I want and wanted you'd
like to be buried next yes yes and that
will happen
yes I think people would like at least
right now well no obviously I don't want
to
be no I mean let's hope it's a a very
long way down the line but but that's
that's settled that's nothing to be no
no
um um I think you know with Riley She's
she's got a great head on her shoulders
she really is and and we've had many
talks um I trust her I I I believe she's
capable of taking taking on some
especially some you know some things
that gray son when we have to be there
in person together or just her and and
you know but after all you turned gross
I and it was losing money it was
basically going out of business you
turned it almost single-handedly
actually I mean you had help but it was
your driving force that's turned into
a100 million a year business I mean it
was an amazing achievement that you did
that I know I sometimes look back at how
in the world did I do this how did you
do
it just rolled up my sle will be proud
of you yeah I just rolled up my sleeves
and it said it has to be done because it
was I was um uh I had two I had uh
Elvis's um bookkeeper and his attorney
the three of us were
Executives they didn't know anything
about Elvis I didn't know his you know
what he wanted what he didn't want they
just took care of
business and I they came to me this is
three years after uh we got
graceand and one of them came to me and
said Priscilla we're in dire need of
money we don't have
we have to sell grin and I just looked
at him and I said that will never happen
he goes but we're out of money I said
that will never happen and then I left
and then I just rolled up my sleeves and
I went out and asked people who you know
as people that I knew I'm looking for
someone to help me do this how do I open
up the home what do I go where do I go
who do I go to how do I do it and then I
just met with with some top people and
it's this huge business but it's also
absolutely in the spirit of Elvis
because it's being driven by someone
that knew what his Spirit was right do
you do you ever go to Grayson oh yes of
course what do you feel like when you go
I feel like I never left really I feel
like I never left I'd go in the house
and sit in the living room and look
around and go my God so many memories
here oh my God I can listen I can hear
Elvis's laughter I can see him playing
the piano after we'd come home from the
theater or the movies um and we'd go in
in the in the um piano room and he'd go
straight to the piano and I'd sit on a
couch and he'd start singing gospel
music that's all all there
still in the Vanity Fair interview that
Riley did she said this about Lisa Marie
her mom the life she had wasn't easy the
treachery she enjoed but like a real
love and real friend she definitely had
some great friends and relationships but
I don't think she ever really had and
then she tells her people were just
coming for her since she was born
wanting something from her not being
totally authentic she had to develop a
thick skin she was a very powerful
presence extremely loving extremely
loyal sort of a lioness a fierce woman
and a really wonderful mother I think
that would be my summary because I'm her
daughter she was the best mom when I
read that I mean you could almost say
exactly the same about you H
wow interesting um
well that's a compliment yeah thank you
it is I just think it's to try and exist
in the Goldfish bowl that you've had to
do that LE had to do all the family have
had to do right you have to have a thick
skin you have to be a bit of a lioness
and none of us are thick skinned then we
have to be right it's true it is true I
mean I chose to be very private I really
I really um I'm not out there that much
I enjoy my friends my my family what I
have left
and and um live live a normal life how
do you feel now we coming to the end of
this actually what's been an
extraordinarily revealing into you far
more than I anticipated me too how do
you feel I don't know maybe I talk too
much I don't know I'm a little nervous
um well I don't know I um I've talked
about things I've never talked about
before I'm at a time in my life where
I'm willing to share and you um I trust
you and I've always liked your you know
your interviews that you've had with
different people and um I hope it comes
out okay I'm sure it will I think people
will feel the same way that I do which
is you're a remarkable person who had a
remarkable life and I'm I'm glad you
have a movie now which is about you and
your life because I think in many ways
it's hugely significant and has been
hugely significant to not just Elvis
when he was alive but also preserving
his legacy since he died I think you've
played such a massive part in that and
that's one of the reasons that he
remains today so revered I think is
because the work and determination
you've had to keep the Elvis flag flying
and I hope this movie I mean I don't
want anyone I know there's a few
comments on him being angry my God he's
a human being he's a human being an
artist and an artist absolutely but he
you know with with Elvis was I've never
met anyone like him and I don't think I
ever will again ever he had a biggest
heart he had a great sense of humor had
a lot of love um he could be a little
kid you know when when he wanted to he
loved to be babied um and he just I I
there's no one like him and the fact
that he still has fans he would never
believe that he would never believe it
ever that he still has and they're
everywhere and they're everywhere but he
um I there'll never be anyone like him
ever Priscilla what a privilege to sit
with you for the last hour thank you
very much for being so open I appreciate
[Music]
it
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
for today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
richy sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pomp you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose I am
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and the national societ party
for the preservation of the habitat of
the Lesser spotted M the problem lies in
the bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like